i'm all right everybody we're going to
get to my first guest um she is ready
now so let's get her in here she was one
of the most iconic
artists of the 90s when she was called
the queen of alt
rock angst by rolling stone she sold
more than 75
million albums worldwide her latest is
called such pretty forks in the road
it's out right now
i love it um let's say hi to atlantis
more set everybody
hi um i'm literally such a big fan that
they were talking to me about
um the design for like our backstage for
this this show
and i wish that you were really at our
show because i would have put you in
your room because
you and annie lennox were my first two
that i like she's one room in your one
room
um there's like several different
dressing rooms and i have the vinyl um
you know of the person on the the door
and it's called that room and you are
one of my rooms because i'm so happy in
one of your rooms
you're one of my rooms it's like what
happens in those rooms though
it's so awesome it's a family show it's
not that baby proud
there's not as cool rock and roll stuff
happening but
um we anyway i have the the jagged
little pillow but honestly i know
everybody talks about jack and little
pill but
i feel like sometimes you're that writer
that like
i mean literally like what people are
thinking or having a hard time with or
struggling with like
it's like you put it and we can't make
the words like we can't get it out and
you do it for us
i mean because a lot of i mean some of
us are writing we write songs we have
fans and
you're like on an epic scale like is
that like is that a lot of pressure like
when you release a record
and and it's it's you know you're so
vulnerable and so
raw and like people are questioning
who's this about what's this about or
you know what are you going through and
is that do you ever think of that
pressure or you just put it out
i felt a lot of pressure after the tour
for jagged little pill finished and it
was time to write
the follow up post you know and um
so i remember going to a studio in
canada with my friend tim when i was
you know under the auspices of starting
to write again and i really didn't want
to write it was that pressure buckle
thing yeah i turned him and i said i
really don't want to write
and he said he was the only person
because everyone else said but your fans
are
you're going to let everybody you know
everyone had an answer that was going to
shame my needing some rest
um but then my friend tim he just turned
to me and he said well let's just go get
a sandwich
and it was the first time that the
pressure had been completely taken off
so we went and watched a movie i think
grabbed some food and then when i came
back i wrote of course the lies such
that i wrote
the first song for the for supposed
former infatuation junkie that
thank you yeah the pressure the pressure
you know i mean i'm assuming you can
relate like every grocery store
you know when the next record coming out
when's the next record coming up so yeah
you know
you know it's art so you kind of have to
wait till you're inspired right
right the receptivity has to it's almost
like i show up this is
this is the filter so it siphons through
my intellect but
the main part is is me being receptive
and more yin
and most of my life i'm such an alpha
and i'm you know i'm in go kind of lean
forward mode so when it comes to writing
i have to sit back and just receive yeah
but then make sure i get it on tape so
it takes however you know a lifetime of
living it and then it for us
or for me it takes 10 minutes to write
it or 15 minutes but
a whole lifetime of living it her new
album is called such pretty forks in the
road
great title um this new album is very
personal you say right so
you get into depression hard emotions
hard conversations so did you have
second thoughts about releasing that i
mean i know that you've always been a
very open writer but
you know it's like especially in this
time when everybody's kind of going
through did you have second thoughts
about releasing it
no actually i used to be terrified in
the night before any release
and then once it's out time and time
again it just became so normal to share
um autobiographically and in a raw way
so
now i'm a lot less afraid and a lot of
people have intimated that
take so much courage to write the way
that i write but for me it takes courage
to talk with people directly and resolve
conflict and bring up something tough or
stand up for myself or whereas in a song
i'm writing that alone in a room no
one's watching me no one cares it's
you know i used to think i could get
away with just writing about it and then
running away and not having to deal with
human beings
but apparently that doesn't work it's
hard though it's hard especially when
you have a lifetime of i'm imagining
you're saying like you know in person
it's a different thing that's probably
took a while to become the bold person
in in person not just in song right
right so people would hear the songs and
they'd imagine they were going to meet
someone at the radio station or wherever
it was and i would walk in and i
whatever i was being that day i might
have been meek or quiet or
more conservative and i think their
perception was that i was going to come
in and just like
rip everything down and spray paint the
walls and just
you know which yeah these days depends
when you catch me at home
but um but yeah i think my main goal
over the last many years has been to
take
to to take the clarity and the empowered
communication that it takes to write a
song and actually apply it
while sitting across from someone where
you know the fight flight freeze kicks
in when we're in conflict but it's not
kicking in when we're writing
when we're writing there's this lucidity
and this flow it feels like and there's
an openness because you're alone in your
own moment
and sometimes i feel like artists were
always surrounded by people and
sometimes we do that and we we choose
that and sometimes it just happens
and so sometimes it's your only like
solace it's your only like place to go
um on your new album um there's a song
called smiling and
i love it so much
like it's because it's not i know a lot
of people will say oh that's for people
in the limelight it's not
that's for people in any vocation like
any
any part of your life you can be having
that moment to where it's like
i'm going through so much but i guess
i'll keep smiling since that's what
everyone's expecting and i and they're
and i'm supposed to be
fine you know and especially as women
too right
i mean we're we're sort of archetypally
almost it's almost like a demand to be
that
hearth overseeing nurturing which is
normal for us in our bodies but we're
also applying ourselves in this whole
yang world too so for me it's it's it's
all these different archetypes that i
love being the teacher the mom the
artist
the activists the outspoken the
you know the channeler the all these
different archetypes and just
the hats you know i mean i'm talking to
you you of all people know
the hats of mom and then producer and
then so just going through all these
different roles
and because of the sensitivity and the
empath qualities i'm just so much more
responsible for making sure i can take
breaks even if it's
hiding in a bathroom i mean i you know
carrying earplugs with me
don't tell anybody no no i'm wearing
them right now
i'm reading your wedding i'm actually
not listening to you
okay yeah you're worried you're saying
ellie
no that's so true i i literally i that's
i i've had this conversation with
someone very close to me and i'm like
i'm not trying to be
rude like when i pull out the earbuds
and like do music i literally
sometimes i'm not even playing anything
right i just want silence i just want a
moment to where i'm not being tucked at
or i don't feel like i'm having to
engage
because i feel like not it's just not
our jobs all draw i feel like we're a
society
a society of oneness like yes to be off
i mean our nervous systems were not
meant to be in in cortisol mode 24 7 and
we're actually
chronic stress in the way that we're all
experiencing
yeah it's like yeah it's constant i know
i know but anyway i just i'm such a fan
and i did find out
somebody told me that you had been to
one of my shows and i'm gonna tell you
if that's true
i am so glad that no one told me you
were there
because i would have a christmas turkey
when people come to my shows whom i
adore i'm like you specifically can't
tell me because that's all i'm going to
think about when i'm on stage
oh no one ever told me not even after
like no one ever and i i literally
there's some strict policy on my
i don't want to know if anyone in the
audience is like
i don't care how fame i don't want to
know because it makes me nervous and i
don't get nervous so
when you're singing are you thinking of
that person the whole time
i did the musical for jack a little pill
and a bunch of the beautiful beautiful
singers performers portrayers came to
see my shows
and unfortunately i'd find out that they
were in the audience before i was
you know and they're the most beautiful
and i just was like oh god and now i
have to watch my pitch and
hit all the right notes and it's
horrifying so i i learned my lesson
probably the the more challenging way
which is my whole show gets
kefled if i know
how is that though i mean like you you
had
i mean you're you have such a great
catalog and you were such a
just a pop culture icon that like they
did a whole musical
i mean is that was that crazy it was it
was the first amount of objectivity i've
ever had on the songs which was cool and
then also
collaboratively i've always felt that
theater was this nomadic
communal village thing that i as a solo
artist
it got pretty lonely on the road just as
a solo artist doing everything kind of
alone
and i know that bands and the beatles
and everyone had their own challenges
for for being a group i get it
but being alone was was a was a rough
one so being in a community of people in
the musical
and diablo cody pulled all the
characters out of the songs themselves
so there's this real kind of integration
between the music and the story and
and and some people were afraid of some
of the content and i just called them
and i said
i got this i will back anything up that
we bring up that is scary and lord knows
diane paulus who directed did tons of
research to be respectful for
in each category of challenge you know
just they did so much research
and i did a little bit myself too and
but i think i woke up i don't think
anyone
it would be upsetting to see something
with your like inspiration your work and
not
see something raw and real and intimate
because it would be so
opposite of you it seems like at least
musically speaking um so i don't know i
just think that's
i mean you've achieved a whole another
level when they're like we want to make
a whole show about it
i'll do a one-person play at some point
or musical play
i have little flashes of it do you have
that where for a long time i just have
images or pictures of where i was
going next and then sometimes it's fully
blank screen i'm like oh
yeah then you're at pretty forks in the
road that's yeah
yeah you know how great americans are
living in the question mark we're not
like oh my god yeah we're all being
asked to do it right now right there's
some pretty big limbo
question marks so our bodies and our
psyches we're in this
we're in this frozen flight place
depends like again where it depends when
you catch us
you know it's so much uncertainty i know
it's a roller coaster for everyone
it's it's so awesome to talk to you i'm
i'm so sorry i talked your face off but
i
live for it i live for it you're so so
good okay
okay oh well everybody be sure to check
out atlantis new album such pretty forks
in the road it's out now
my favorite smiling but whatever
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going